et d'abord avec la flambée des prix de
l'énergie cette question qui est reçue
rhji pour atteindre l'objectif zéro
carbone de la france en 2050 peut-on se
passer du nucléaire samia de chiens en
france la production d'énergie est déjà
largement décarbonée le nucléaire en
représentent près de 80% plus de 20% est
issu d'énergies renouvelables comme les
barrages hydrauliques l'éolien le
photovoltaïque l'énergie thermique et la
valorisation de déchets moins de 1% est
issue des énergies fossiles la france
serait elle alors championne du monde
des énergies décarbonées pas vraiment
car on importe bien plus d'énergie qu'on
en produit côté consommation le bilan
est donc bien moins reluisant en termes
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre près
de 30% de l'énergie que nous consommons
est d'origine pétrolière plus de 15%
bien du gaz 40% du nucléaire est un peu
plus de 10% d'énergies renouvelables au
total près de la moitié de notre énergie
consommée et donc d'origine fossile pour
verdir notre mix énergétique la loi
climat prévoit de réduire de 40 % notre
consommation d'énergie fossile d'ici
2030 il faut que ce qu'on utilise avec
du pétrole dont de tourner vers
l'électricité les voitures électriques
le chauffage et puis aussi évidemment
essayer d'être plus efficace en de
baisser notre consommation
on a des projections qui nous disent que
tous ces changements que nous sommes en
train de faire vont faire augmenter la
demande d'électricité d'ici 15 ans pour
augmenter la production d'électricité on
n'a pas le choix on va pas avoir qu'un
nouvelle centrale nucléaire en quinze
ans ça n'existe pas donc on doit
développer les renouvelables absolument
d'ici 2030 la france doit porter la part
des énergies renouvelables de 11 à 33%
dans sa consommation énergétique totale
le gouvernement prévoit aussi de réduire
la part du nucléaire
14 réacteurs doit fermer d'ici 2035
la france peut-elle se passer du
nucléaire voilà le thème de notre débat
d'actualité je vous présente mes invités
alexandre moustardier bonsoir bienvenue
avocat soucis au cabinet atmo
spécialiste en droit de l'environnement
myrtho tripathi bonsoir bienvenue
ingénieurs présidente de l'association
voix du nucléaire et ronan dantec
bonsoir sur un feignant sénateur
écologiste de loire-atlantique laetitia
cru pas l'éditorialiste de sens public
tous les mardis et jeudis bon soirée est
bienvenu laetitia j'aime bien souvent
commencé les débats par la question
générale pour voir comment chacun se
situe la france peut-elle se passer du
nucléaire tient je commence avec vous
bientôt tripathi écouté ma réponse ne va
surprendre personne je pense qu'elle
peut pas elle ne peut pas s'en passer
mais surtout elle ne devrait pas s'en
passer et son histoire récente et son
développement économique et le bien-être
de sa population je pense sont des
facteurs qui qui encourage à cette
conclusion et il est important d'arriver
à tirer les conclusions de ce qu'on a
vécu de ce qu'on a mis en oeuvre et
parfois se rendent compte qu'on a pris
des bonnes décisions et qu'elles sont
confirmées par les faits et qu'il s'agit
de les poursuivre et pas forcément de
remettre en cause des choses qui n'ont
pas lieu d'être alors évidemment ensuite
on aura le temps de détailler aux
arguments aux uns et aux autres monsieur
le sénateur bah écoutez si vous nous
dites est ce qu'on peut débrancher tous
les centrales nucléaires demain matin je
vous répondrais non ce qui est une
évidence si on doit se passer du
nucléaire pour des raisons assez simple
de bonne santé économique de la france à
horizon de 20 30 ans c'est une évidence
pour tous ceux qui savent compter faire
dire la différence entre 60 euros prix
du photovoltaïque 120 euros prix du
nucléaire
donc effectivement l'avenir industriel
de la france passe par une sortie en
bonheur du nucléaire c'est une évidence
économique pour vous ça prend combien de
temps potentiellement ça va dépendre
fonds de roulement oui non mais c'est la
question centrale ça dépend
fondamentalement du niveau
d'investissement annuel sur cette
transition énergétique et notamment
aussi l'efficacité énergétique parce que
par exemple isolé une maison c'est moins
de besoin un d'énergie ou moins de
besoins d'énergie fossile en premier
disons que je pense qu'à 20 ans avec des
investissements lourds de plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'euros par an on
peut y arriver et est sur le scénario de
l'ademe mois j'invente rien je prends
que les scénarios de l'état elle est
est-ce que l'état étudie avec un gain
pour l'économie française et la société
française de l'ordre de 250 milliards
d'euros par an si on est sur un scénario
100% énergies renouvelables plutôt que
nucléaire 250 milliards c'est beaucoup
d'argent pour la santé oui un gars
rentrent et dans l'économie française et
des habitants de ce sera l'un des
aspects du débat évidemment le gain
économique aux guerres en matière
d'emploi je suis pas sûr que tout le
monde sera d'accord alexandre
moustardier votre point de vue la
réponse est non pour plusieurs raisons
parce qu'il ya ce qu'on veut faire et à
ce qu'on peut faire
l'incantation c'est formidable les
chiffres on leur fait dire ce qu'on veut
on a des chiffres de 150 milliards mais
par exemple on peut dire que si demain
on veut remplacer toutes les centrales
nucléaires par des éoliennes il faut
couvrir 5 % du territoire français par
des éoliennes et de toute façon ils y
apprennent majeur c'est que les
éoliennes ne sont pas ne constitue pas
une source d'énergie disponible en
permanence et ça sera je pense un des
sujets de discussion c'est que l'éolien
ne n'apporte pas une source d'énergie
donc si on veut ce prix me plaire faut
accepter de faire comme l'allemagne
c'est à dire s'asseoir sur les accords
de paris repartir sur énergie fossile
avec le charbon et accepter d'être à
nouveau un émetteur de gaz à effet de
serre
l'énergie chère c'est pour longtemps
commence avec vous avec son style c'est
pour longtemps hélas on est au coeur de
l'actualité de cette soirée je ne sais
pas c'est pour longtemps parce qu'on
sait que le prix d'énergie avec les
années baisse et montrent ce qui est
clair c'est que ça renforce je dirais la
nécessité d'avoir une indépendance
énergétique
l'éolien constituent une source
d'énergie indépendante le nucléaire
aussi puisqu'on a une forme
d'indépendance les énergies fossiles
sont ne sont pas sûrs de ne ne
permettent pas une indépendance donc on
a vraisemblablement une tendance à la
hausse une stabilité vers une énergie
chère c'est l'occasion et je rejoins
monsieur le sénateur de réfléchir un
vrai projet d'investissement ou continue
à aller vers une indépendance
énergétique éolien est un mix
énergétique mais je pense qu'on en
reparlera parce que le sujet c'est
vraiment le mix énergétique c'est
évident le mix énergétique
évidemment il ya la réponse on va dire à
court terme très politique laetitia
parce que le prix de l'énergie a de quoi
raviver les braises d'un mouvement comme
celui dédié jaune évidemment oui bien
sûr c'est la plaie ouverte du
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron donc le
gouvernement surveille cette colère
sociale qu'on ne cesse d'annoncer nous
dans les médias mais aussi tous les
observateurs parce que directement ça va
impacter le porte monnaie de tous les
français donc et comme on n'a pas
beaucoup de levier 1,2 pour changer ce
prix on va tenter de calmer cette colère
qui pourrait descendre dans la rue et le
constat il est fait par tous en fait
c'est ça qui est frappant c'est qu'il ya
une unanimité sur ce constat dans les
médias et chez les politiques je vous
propose d'écouter ségolène royal s'était
mardi aux 4 vérités sur france 2 la
flambée du prix de l'énergie et de
l'essence c'est une bombe sociale à
retardement qui va venir très rap comme
les jeunes comme les juges les gilet
jaune mais elle sait plus violentes les
gilet jaune parce que cette hausse est
bien supérieure à celle de la taxe
carbone quand est ce que les gilet jaune
se sont mis sur les rangs points
notamment les femmes retraitées c'est au
mois de novembre voyez on est au mois de
septembre
donc il faut absolument que cette
question soit réglée avant d'aller au
delà de ce constat évidemment il ya une
réaction de l'exécutif c'est le premier
ministre qui monte au front oui c'est
évidemment régler avant novembre puisque
il faut encore une fois éteindre les
braises qui ne serait pas éteinte en
fait c'est ça le constat partagé par
tous et donc emmanuel macron a ouvert le
conseil des ministres hier avec cette
question il a déjeuné avec jean castex à
la suite de ce conseil des ministres
pour mettre en place toutes les mesures
annoncées dans le 20h et jean castex on
comprend maintenant pourquoi il a changé
de premier ministre emmanuel macron
parce qu' edouard philippe c'était quand
même le symbole de la faillite du
dialogue aucun dialogue ne s'est
instauré avec cette france dit gilet
jaune et donc avec jean castex qui est
ancré dans les territoires il va s'en
servir finalement pendant toute la
campagne comme d'un paratonnerre social
jean castex et celui qui va aller au
contact des français à porter
des solutions claires durable et surtout
concrète c'est à dire que les français
doivent voir tout de suite l'apport en
fait de l'état quand il y a comme ça une
montée une flambée des prix de l'énergie
merci laetitia ronan dantec est ce que
cette question je reviens à notre
question centrale mais qui a évidemment
une résonance politique dans cette
campagne présidentielle est ce que pour
vous elle est suffisamment abordé ou est
ce qu'elle doit devenir finalement 1,1
point de structuration du débat
politique de cette ça devrait être un
des points de structuration parce que
quand on parle de 250 milliards de gains
pour l'économie française et la vie des
français chaque année c'est bien plus
que ce qu'on a injectés après la crise
du coc vide sur un changement de mix
énergétique à dos et renouvelables on
est au coeur en fête de la réalité du
quotidien des français sauf que on est
dans un débat et c'est pour ça que j'ai
pris beaucoup de notes aujourd'hui avec
moi qu'il faut à finir avec les débats
folklorique sur le fait qu' on assène
des trucs à lundi blanc l'audi rouge et
puis personne n'y comprend rien il faut
prendre que les chiffres de l'état que
les études de l'état que les skis et
négociés sur les marchés parce que là on
est avec des gens qui sont pas des
poètes et sur les marchés c'est très
clair et à l'échelle mondiale je suis
très très investis à l'échelle mondiale
sur les questions climat énergie il est
très clair que on est les derniers au
monde à croire au nucléaire salut tout
le monde essaye d'en sortir en bon nord
et en à cette espèce de déclin français
que certains d'ailleurs instrumentalise
temps le fait qu'on a fait des erreurs
stratégiques surtout des erreurs de
lutte à sion qu'on a retardé dans les
années 90 2000 et que maintenant il faut
rattraper le temps perdu et rattraper le
temps perdu y compris pour l'optimisme
de la société française et pour sa
cohésion je rappelle juste sur les gilet
jaune un débat que j'ai eu avec gérald
darmanin dans l'hémicycle au sénat au
moment de l'augmentation de la taxe
carbone que je défends des parce qu'on a
besoin de flux financiers justement pour
financer cette transition en lui disant
vous augmenter le prix du carbone très
bien mais cet argent doit aller au
territoire doit aller aux français sinon
ça ne sera pas accepté et il se retourne
vers moi en rigolant on dit pourquoi pas
les bonnets rouges il a vu les gilets
jaunes donc il ya eu effectivement une
erreur massive de ce gouvernement dans
le fait que cette taxe carbone n'a pas
été mis au service des français de leur
quotidien et du développement économique
des territoires on le paye aujourd'hui
mais effectivement il est temps de faire
une vraie priorité sur la transition et
de mettre aussi nos outils financiers y
compris européens la biu la bce sur
cette transition nécessaire qui créera
de l'emploi et bien ce sera la facture
énergétique des français bon les bonnets
rouges on s'en souvient mais c'était
l'époque ségolène royal et ses échos
taxer ces portiques qu'on voit sur les
routes les autoroutes et qui ne servent
à rien depuis des années alors moi je
vouvoyais prendre des notes milito
tripathi parce que vous avez vraiment de
vision alors pour le couple radicalement
opposées de l'avenir énergétique de la
france et de ce qui va faire le bien de
notre société ben écoute et oui moi je
suis très surprise
des propos de monsieur
l'étude de l'ademe con mais oui mais
j'ai aussi
les études de la cour des comptes les
rapports du giec
des comptes fédérale allemande sur la
transition énergétique allemand donc
j'ai effectivement lu beaucoup de choses
et pas uniquement les productions des
des institutions qui vont dans son sens
je pense que c'est important si on veut
garder une certaine objectivité moi ce
que je vois et je pense que c'est
important de s'appuyer sur ce qu'on peut
constater c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
nucléaire français est l'énergie la plus
décarbonés de france est probablement la
ngr pup décarbonés d'europe donc pour ce
qui est des enjeux climatiques et
peut-être les barrages hydrauliques qui
font un petit peu mieux en terme
le nucléaire français est entre 4 et 6
grammes de co2 par kilowattheure les
barrages hydrauliques vont plutôt être
entre 5 et 12 selon les situations bref
quoi ceux-ci poté sur les
deux entrées tout le béton et
d'exploitation au niger et à bages et
que je lis les analyses n'ont cédé chez
lui pour que l'on puisse vérifier parce
que maintenant à bâle ou propose que et
de lennon je vous propose que dans ce
débat tout chiffre on dise d'où il vient
alors quelles études
l'étude de l'ademe d'accord vous allez
avoir logique le jour toujours comme ça
qu'on comptabilise le giec va vous
donner 12 pour le nucléaire puisque
c'est moyenne mondiale
et puis vous allez avoir edf qui veut
donner qu'être entre 4 et 4,7 et la
raison de cela c'est que il ya un très
très gros consommateurs d'électricité
qui intervient dans la chaîne de
production du nucléaire qui sont les
usines d'enrichissement qui a été
remplacé récemment et qui abaisse la
facture électrique de la production de
l'électricité elle-même énormément et
donc à baisser la facture donc si je
reviens sur mon propos donc aujourd'hui
le nucléaire énergie la pluie décarbonés
de france
le climat est en tête des préoccupations
des français y compris désormais de plus
en plus les classes moyennes et
populaires et aussi les segments les
plus âgés de la population qui était
peut être un peu moins sensibilisés et
que les précédents aujourd'hui grâce au
nucléaire et c'est quand même assez
significatif puisqu'il fait entre 77 75
% voire 80% de l'électricité française
on bénéficie d'une d électricité les
moins chers d'europe alors que nos amis
allemands qui tendent qui essaye avec
beaucoup de difficultés d'aller vers une
économie 100 % renouvelable aujourd'hui
une facture d'électricité qui le double
de ce que vous vous êtes basé sur le
prix de le père ou sur les centres des
gens là je me base sur les chiffres de
l'union européenne et
le prix c'est le prix de centrales qui
est fournie à 80% par le parc nucléaire
français donc hic les punks je le
rappelle est à 120 euros le
oui pardon mais moi là j'ai par exemple
du mal à comprendre la phrase qui menait
de prononcé donc j'aimerais que nous
téléspectateurs soit pas perdue par la
dette risque
je suis d'abord trois dangers reprend la
main deux aussi d'accord avec vous pour
sourcer les chiffres mais nous noyer pas
s'il vous plaît dans les dents les
éléments trop technique se termine en
électricité française est une des moins
chères d'europe avec une très très part
importante très très importante du
nucléaire dans le mix plus de 80% et
puis une énergie dont la souveraineté
est un regret puisque on a à peu près 95
% de la valeur de la production du
nucléaire français qui fait en france
et donc on est très exposé on est très
peu exposé à la aux acteurs extérieurs
aujourd'hui l'explosion du prix du gaz
c'est la contraction de l'offre par les
russes et par les américains avec une
plus grande difficulté des norvégiens à
fournir le complément sur la question du
nucléaire on n'a pas ce problème là le
règne aura beaucoup emmanuel macron
demande à ce qu'on ait justement moins
de dépendance énergétique à d'autres
puissances ça c'est vraiment une phrase
qui est ressorti du conseil des
ministres le gouvernement donne en
éléments de langage quand ça ressort ça
veut dire que c'est vraiment une
affirmation de l'exécutif donc pourquoi
il dit ça alors ben alors parce que le
nucléaire fait de l'électricité et
l'électricité c'est moins d'un quart de
la facture énergétique française service
115 % de l'énergie qu'on consomme qui
sont des combustibles fossiles émetteur
de gaz à effet de serre qui sont
d'ailleurs la priorité à laquelle on
devrait s'inquiéter plutôt que se
préoccuper de remplacer une énergie
décarbonée par une autre je pense que
c'est vraiment pas le débat aujourd'hui
et qu'on se focalise sur le nucléaire
mais l'unique leers année entre
guillemets que l'électricité et cette
électricité française elle et 95%
françaises elle s'appuie sur une matière
première qui est l'uranium qui ne
constitue que deux entre 2 et 5% du prix
final du kilowatt à ça veut dire que le
prix de l'uranium peut exploser sur le
marché ça fera quelques centimes sur la
facture des réponses à l'électricité va
augmenter aussi et qui en plus alors on
vient y règne homme qui en plus ne sert
à rien d'autre qu'à ça l'udac ahmad
usage compétitif on va avoir 12 %
d'augmentation alors ça c'est pour une
raison très simple qui est que le marché
d'électricité européen est entièrement
intégré que en l'occurrence sur le
marché le prix de l'électricité vendue
sur le marché allemand exactement le
même que celui sur marché français donc
en france on est exposé sur nos prix de
marché à haut prix l'électricité
européen alors jouer contre eux on a nos
tarifs régulés sur base au nucléaire
historique
sur la question de évidemment du
nucléaire de notre parc de centrales
nucléaires et la question de la sécurité
parce qu'évidemment c'est un des
arguments majeurs en la matière
les centrales nucléaires
est-ce qu'elles vieillissent peut-être
que vous pouvez répondre à cette
question alexandre moustardier escale
bis au point d'être plus dangereuse
aujourd'hui et où potentiellement
dangereuses dans les dix ou vingt ans à
venir alors moi je fais du droit je ne
fais ni technique oui oui je le disais
donc je vais essayer de répondre à votre
question peut-être votre wii mais votre
perception expérimentation confiance
dans le pape et en france elles
vieillissent alors elles vieillissent
oui elles vieillissent parce que paris
on voit que il ya un d eux père qui ont
du mal à sortir et qui ont des retards
majeurs pendant ce temps là le pari et
puis a surtout un point qui est parce
que on parle on a un discours moi je ne
suis ni pro ni anti nucléaires jemâa là
pour ça je vous dis une fois encore je
ne fais que du droit mais il ya quand
même un point qu'on oublie c'est qu'on
nous parle du coup l'électricité
aujourd'hui on oublie de parler votre
question tout à fait opportune du
démantèlement de ses centrales parce
qu'on a beau tirer au maximum sur la
durée de vie à un moment il faut faire
la démanteler et on ne parle jamais ou
en tout cas très peu des milliards des
dizaines de milliards qu'il va falloir
dépenser pour démanteler ces centrales
donc dans les chiffres qu'on évoque il
faut effectivement investir sur les
énergies renouvelables il faut soit
peut-être réduire le nucléaire et garder
les meilleurs centrale entre guillemets
en tout cas celles qui sont encore en
bout de course et puis commencer à être
tout à fait honnête et dire il va
falloir dépenser des dizaines de
milliards pour démanteler ces centrales
qui sont pour certaines vraiment enfin
durée vie elles sont toutes au delà de
la durée de vie qu'on leur avait
attribué au départ il faut le savoir
nous l'a déjà dépassé c'est ce que oui
c'est déjà dépassées et c'est alors
maintenant d'un seul coup elle était
faite pour durer 40 ans mais on dit non
mais en faisant ça et ça elles peuvent
durer 50 ans le peuple peut-être la
technologie évolue et on a conçu les
centrales nucléaires des années 60 la
technologie a évolué depuis mais
néanmoins je pense qu'il faut penser à
ce démantèlement quelle durée de vie
alors les centrales françaises n'ont pas
de durée de vie ça c'est réalité du jour
de leur construction les centrales
françaises ne sont pas construites avec
dans l'esprit durée de vie leur
opérationnalité j'ai envie de dire et
rêver lui tous les dix ans elles sont
immortels à dire que si non ça veut dire
que si au bout de dix ans elles ne
répondent pas aux nouvelles normes et
une nouvelle exigeante parce que ces
exigences évoluent fukushima et intégrer
les différents retours d'expériences
mondiaux sont intégrés régulièrement
elles vont s'arrêter au bout de dix ans
si comme leur soeur jumelle américaine
qui d'ailleurs sont un peu plus vieille
que les centrales françaises elles
viennent d'être étendu à 80 ans si elles
vont jusqu'à 80 ans à zéro jusqu'à 91
ans mais on ne leur donne pas comme ça
donc cela dure le temps que je contrôle
on se repose la question alors dix ans
et tous les dix ans refait l'exercice de
savoir si elles peuvent durer dix ans
plus et ça coûte si cher que ça bébés
non plus alors écoutez cour des comptes
je pense à mon ami le sénateur donc un
certain nombre d'ailleurs de rapport de
la cour des comptes relativement récent
le dernier 2017 il me semble
le coût du démantèlement est réévaluée
régulièrement par la puissance publique
est intégré dans le coût du
kilowattheure donc une payons déjà se
pose
faut il faut ont pris la gesture d'aidé
intégré aujourd'hui dans les comptines
rohff en permanence mais un moment on
peut pas tout accepter c'est faux
écoutez c'est les premiers
une commission d enquête du sénat ya dix
ans qui le disaient noir sur blanc que
la commission d' enquête du sénat ce
qu'elle fait les commissions d'enquêté
ce qu'elles font c'est qu'elle réévalue
régulièrement de savoir si les
provisions que edf entreprise privée dé
comparer un cercle entreprise privée met
de côté et intègre et intègre la gestion
de ces fonds de provisions dans son prix
du kilowattheure comme ferait toute
entreprise humaine est ce que ils sont
encore suffisamment dimensionné sol il
ya des réévaluations régulières et
parfois des se fêtait palais dans les
grands en lui disant
essayer de poser un débat un peu
rationnel dit si vous me le permettez
déclarations du président d'autorité
sûreté nucléaire on joue en 2021 c'était
bahia disant rien de garanti qu'une
prolongation supplémentaire donc il
parle bien de prolongation il parle pas
de centrale qui serait immortel qu'une
prolongation de suppléments ce que j'ai
l'air française soit possible elles ont
été conçues ce sont ses mots pour 40 ans
rebelote là
quelques semaines après il y a en france
un déficit de culture de précaution si
on le nucléaire c'est l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
relativement simple on a fait un choix
dans les années 70 de m absolument
toutes nos billes dans le même panier et
nous avons aujourd'hui un parc nucléaire
vieillissant qui avait été prévu pour 40
ans donc personne ne sait comment il va
évoluer dans les dix prochaines années
c'est l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui
le dit qui pourrait avoir par exemple un
problème surtout des centrales peu près
au même endroit même pièce qui vit et on
sera en grande difficulté qu'est-ce qui
vous parce que là vous notionnels c'est
un conditionnel bien sûr moi je suis en
politique je suis pour une société
robuste avec 2,3 principe de précaution
dire que tout le monde énergie et sur la
même technologie quelle vie et que toute
personne ne sait comment elle dépasse
les 40 ans pour lesquels étaient précis
prévu je me dis si je suis un garçon
raisonnable je diversifie mon mix mais
le débat n'est pas là dessus le débat
n'est pas là dessus ce parc nucléaire on
va le faire durer parce qu'on n'a pas le
choix tout simplement donc on va le
faire durer encore dix ans vingt ans
pour certaines centrales la question
fondamentale ses caisses et tout le
lobby nucléaire et là dessus
est-ce qu'on fait pendant ces vingt ans
qui viennent est ce que comme le propose
y compris rte le 10 10 ans 100% énergies
renouvelables en france c'est possible
techniquement possible il faut changer
les réseaux font changer la forme avec
une territorialisation sa plus forte
mais le sait pas ce qui peut se passer
présenté dimanche au site
comment passer au rythme en est
d'ailleurs 80% des technologies sur
lesquelles ce scénario s'appuie ne sont
aujourd'hui à l'état de r&d ou de
démonstration sur vous vous dites on n'a
pas la technologie pour passer la
crise a encore c'est possible les
rapports de l'ademe 6/10 c'est possible
simplement ça veut dire qu'il ya
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
par an qui dans un cas iront plutôt un
lobby installé quai le lobby nucléaire
et qui dans l'autre cas iront sur les
territoires iront aussi beaucoup sur les
pentes des particuliers qui sont en fait
les principaux producteurs en
photovoltaïque puisque la grosse
capacité française allait en
photovoltaïque avec du photovoltaïque
aujourd'hui au portugal qui a huit fois
moins cher que le contrat d'edf sur rien
que les bonnes sur le père dean club
volt en grandes bretelles donc on est
vraiment sur un changement de logiciel
avec les territoires qui prennent la
main et les retombées économiques pour
le territoire c'est là qu'est le débat
c'est le vrai débat est là les deux
solutions sont techniquement possible
continuez dans le nucléaire avec des
nouvelles centrales où passait au 100%
renouvelable la différence c'est que
dans un cas l'électricité produite sera
bien moins cher ça c'est le renouvelable
et ça ira aux particuliers et aux
territoires dans le cas c'est une
industrie installés qui garde en fait le
pactole bien compris il ya quand même
une question centrale pour pour
atteindre cet objectif et
sur cette question du mix énergétique
c'est la question de l'acceptation de
ces nouvelles sources d'énergie
renouvelables notamment évidemment vous
voyez venir l'énergie éolienne tiens on
va on va demander à quand un calme et de
nous rejoindre pour faire une première
illustration on va parler d'un secteur
particulier quand un bon soir je
récupère ma fiche c'est l'éolien au
chaud ou l'éolien maritime alors ça
commence à peine à poindre à voir le
jour en france exactement je vous ai
ramené quelques images pour l'occasion
ils ont été tourné il ya deux semaines
le tout premier parc éolien est
installée au large de saint nazaire
tient pour l'heure seuls les 80
fondation vous voyez ici l'association
ici en jaune en acier elles ont pour
l'instant juste été posée la mise en
service doit intervenir fin 2022 alors
tous ces éoliennes doivent à terme
fournir l'électricité de 700 mille
personnes nous dit edf c'est 20% des
foyers de loire atlantique
il s'agit du premier de quatre parcs
déjà à lens et qui est élancée 1 depuis
2009 mais avec beaucoup de procédures
administratives des plaintes des recours
qui ont retardé leur mise en place et
les chantiers donc les trois autres
chantiers vont aussi bientôt démarrer au
danemark ça fait 30 ans que ces
technologies existent et dans toute
l'union européenne on compte plus de
5000 de ses structures nerfs et le
royaume uni est l'un des pays d'europe
voir le pays d'europe le mieux équipé
exactement un boris johnson a même parlé
l'an dernier d'une promesse qu'il
faisait toutes les maisons britannique
qui seraient alimentés par des éoliennes
d'ici 2030 là bas on parle de wind farm
ce dont on parle de ses champs
d'éoliennes le pays veut devenir le
leader mondial dans la production de
cette énergie en devenant dixit encore
boris johnson l'arabie saoudite de
l'énergie éolienne alors pour l'heure au
total la grande bretagne ne dispose que
de 11 mille éoliennes en mer enfin c'est
quand même et non en fait voilà ce que
nous on en a
mais effectivement ça ne se produit 25%
2 energy en grande bretagne avec un
problème thomas c'est que lorsque le
vent ne souffle pas et bien une baisse
de production on est dans un article qui
est paru il ya quelques jours c'est ce
qui s'est passé début septembre où seuls
7 % du mix venait de sewen lieu de 25
parce qu'il a fallu rallumer les
centrales à gaz et à charbon et à ce
moment là les prix ils existent et ont
doublé en grande-bretagne comme quoi
c'est pas si simple merci beaucoup quant
à effectivement cette question du
l'acceptation de l'éolien et sans
moustardier on est où on est au coeur de
l'avenir énergétique de notre pays à ce
syndrome on va reprendre une expression
anglo-saxonne ce syndrome nimby not in
my backyard my backyard dont on pourrait
dire pas de ça chez moi c'est vrai que
c'est l'une des constantes heureusement
ou malheureusement je ne vais pas
prendre parti de de ce débat sur le mix
énergétique alors c'est un vrai problème
de fond pour citer puisque le sénateur
en tête qu'on cite ses sources je ne
dérogerai pas la règle le rapport du
groupe de travail de l'éolien en 2018
relève donc ses pas il ya 20 ans en 2018
et les évolutions sont faibles
70% des autorisations 70 % font l'objet
de contentieux c'est à dire que vous
avez au conseil d'état près 200
décisions sur les 15 années au conseil
d'état qui concerne l'éolien tout cela
ça veut bien dire ce que vous venez de
souligner certains prennent
d'acceptabilité c'est-à-dire kurt
plainte les communes alors ce sont les
riverains les riverains souvent faut
voir que les éoliennes s'installent dans
des campagnes et que ça peut gêner des
riverains secondaires parfois on voit
des projets se verrait
ça peut être aussi des secondaires parce
que ça les rageux parce que les pales ça
fait du bruit parce que ont présenté aux
liens comme quelque chose formidable
mais aucune énergie des sources d'eau
qu'une nuisance dire que l'éolien fait
du bruit il ya tout un débat sur les
champs électromagnétiques et sur les
l'impact sur la santé des humains et des
animaux donc c'est pas ça donc il ya des
riverains c'est pas forcément les
communes et communes finalement elle s'y
oppose assez peu souvent elles modifient
leur paie lui ceux qui ont les terrains
qui supporte les éoliennes touche des
loyers donc c'est intéressant c'est
véritablement des riverains ça peut être
des résidents secondaires des raisons
principaux des agriculteurs parce qu'ils
ont peur pour leur cheptel
il ya véritablement un défaut
d'acceptabilité et ça c'est pour ça
quand j'entends le miz la transition
écologique dire il faut multiplier par
deux affectés ce sont des incantations
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas je le
disais en introduction il ya ce qu'on
veut et ce qu'on peut c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui le même si on a un peu
fait veut la procédure en supprimant un
degré de juridiction il ya des
bricolages procéduraux qui ont été faits
j'appelle ça des bricolages mais c'est
pas avec ça qu'on passera en force et
recueilli un passage en force qui est
voulu mais qui ne peut pas passer à
cause du droit parce que finalement on
est dans un pays de droit un état de
droit et on en revient toujours au droit
est aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
recours et en dehors même des recours
c'est vrai pour l'éolien intéresse et
l'éolien en mer bien sûr
d'acceptabilité au site est très simple
c'est que vous on évoquait là le royaume
uni il ya quand même chose qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est que les français
n'aiment pas avoir sur leurs côtes des
éoliennes mais c'est pas uniquement pour
ce qu'ils voient c'est parce que la
france est la première nation
touristique du monde et que les côtes
anglaises complètement fréquentée par
les touristes mais toutes les communes
du littoral qui se remplissent l'été de
touristes n'ont pas envie d'avoir sous
les yeux des éoliennes donc c'est un
problème général d'acceptabilité on ne
peut pas faire un passage en force en
disant comme l'a fait le ministre savait
doubler d'ici x années c'est comme ça et
pas autrement et en plus il faut changer
la loi on a commencé à faire mes 30 ans
quelques mois il ya une élection
présidentielle et que là pour l'instant
marine le pen avait bertrand peut-être
le potentiel candidat eric zemmour se
sont tous tous tous tous vraiment voilà
pour positionner contre les éoliennes
ils l'ont fait savoir c'est même devenu
cet été j'ai deux hommes politiques de
polémique politique qui était assez oui
c'est 30 effet d'acceptabilité dont
alors sommet sur un défaut d'accepter la
suite aux chiffres avant de vous donner
la parole ronan dantec sur justement les
français et l'éolien c'est un sondage au
doxa qui avait été commandée par le
medef alors des des adjectifs comment
jugez-vous l'énergie éolienne moins
risqués 82% moins polluantes 69% peu
d'impact sur la biodiversité 59% ensuite
sur l'image avez vous une image positive
des énergies éoliennes donc c'est un
sondage tour et 101 73 3% avec une
baisse très forte - 17 points en deux
ans ça c'est quand même un point sur
lequel je vais vous entendre monsieur le
sénateur et puis ça c'est intéressant
aussi ou alors image positive 63% mais
seriez-vous favorable à l'installation
d'une éolienne près de chez vous et là
dans le monde et dans le syndrome immuno
de préparer et là c'est 53% de non cette
baisse -17 points en deux ans ronan
dantec c'est quand même une difficulté
majeure dans la logique où la stratégie
qui est porté par par les verts par
europe écologie verts c'est vrai mais
les chiffres montrent une adhésion forte
quand même c'est à dire merci alors
quand même j'ai quand même la chance de
vivre quasiment dans le paradis
terrestre la loire atlantique vous et
venez le montrer le parc éolien de saint
nazaire aucun recours les marins
pêcheurs sont pour les marins pêcheurs
sont pour j'ai inauguré d'éolien
terrestre
il ya trois mois à côté dans dans le
pays de retz où aucun recours important
la loire atlantique vous leur mettez un
projet de centrale nucléaire il le passe
par dessus bord vous leur mettez un
projet d'aéroport ils le passent par
dessus bord dans le genre on sait
résister au projet et faire en sorte
qu'ils ne se fâchent ne se fasse pas on
est quand même au coeur des résistants
alors qu'est ce qu'ils avaient fait de
différent pour que c'est parce que je
pense qu'on est avec des gens
responsables qui ont bien les prix tous
les autres départements sont tirés son
teint pâle et
d'information
vive la bretagne aucune centrale à la
loire atlantique n'est pas en bretagne
plusieurs échecs des éoliennes le cap
sizun où ils ont refusé à plogoff la
santé via une centrale à gaz bravo cet
été la centrale seront
bientôt avoir un câble qui viendra dire
non et qui sera à oublier à l'éolien
offshore des îles britanniques ce que ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que
effectivement il y a aujourd'hui dans un
certain nombre d'endroits un problème
d'acceptabilité qu'il y ait des gens qui
se dit j'ai une éolienne à deux pilotes
de chez moi auxerre je vais pas
longtemps mais peut-être que ce avoir un
impact sur le sur la valeur de ma
résidence secondaire là effectivement on
a des gens dans l'égoïsme nimby qui ne
sont pas responsables par rapport aux
enjeux de la société ça existe mais tu
néanmoins il ya un vrai problème
effectivement et peut-être que là bas je
réponds à votre question peut-être que
la baisse est liée de popularité liée à
ça même si majoritairement les français
restent très favorables à la transition
énergétique et nucléaire les cils sont
beaucoup plus mauvais pour le nucléaire
en termes de soutien donc c'est quand
même plutôt la léchère on les a les
chiffres l'image positive de l'énergie
nucléaire c'est oui 51 % avec nous avec
une hausse assez forte mais
la tendance et puis quelques quelques et
donc pardon quelques adjectifs g au bout
comment vous jugez l'énergie nucléaire
on essaye de faire le parallèle efficace
67% préserver les paysages 57% peu
coûteuse 51% on a choisi les adjectifs
positifs des deux côtés mais donc pour
répondre à votre question je pense
qu'effectivement on a un problème
aujourd'hui d'acceptabilité de l'éolien
dans un certain nombre de régions parce
que l'état n'a pas le courage d'aller
vers finalement une répartition assez
équitable de l'effort éolien moi je dis
pas qu'il n'ya pas d'effort du tout dans
le fait que dans le paysage on est des
éoliennes c'est une part d'efforts c'est
un effort raisonnable dans un pays où
chacun a envie d'avoir de l'électricité
pas cher et
de lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique en baissant ses émissions
mais on voit bien qu'il ya des régions
qui ont refusé des régions qui sont
retrouvés beaucoup puisqu'on est dans un
système très libérale finalement
extrêmement libérale et qu'il faut
changer ce système qu'il faut mieux
répartir qu'il faut absolument sortir
d'un système capitaine sauvage qui
existe sur certains avec certaines
entreprises éoliennes et qu'il faut
absolument qu'ils aient des retours
d'investissement pour les particuliers
qui sont très demandeurs sur le
territoire loire atlantique c'est très
net les particuliers veulent investir
dans l'éolien il ya beaucoup de parcs
oui mais sans très soutenue dans les
yeux là on va parler des pêcheurs de
saint brieuc vient de retrouver l'info
que je cherchais c'est
franceinfo.fr keenu kim kim l'a fourni
le parquet d'éolien offshore qui est en
construction dans la baie de saint
brieuc projet d'une soixantaine
d'éoliennes lancée il ya plus de dix ans
travaux de forage de fondations qui ont
commencé il ya cinq mois il est marin
pêcheur qui sont ils
évidemment j'ai regardé les deux parcs
mais de manière attentive j'ai participé
à ces activement aux projets sur saint
nazaire au moment de l' enquête publique
je crois qu'il ya une attention portée
aux demandes locales sur saint nazaire y
compris construction quand même des
nacelles sur le territoire et créations
d'emplois sur le territoire n'en est
rien et qu'on n'a pas eu la même
attention certainement et c'est pas le
même je suppose que j'ai cité les uns
les autres mais c'est clairement pas le
même investisseur qui est derrière le
parc à saint brieuc et que si on ne fait
pas attention à la qualité du débat
public à la qualité d'association des
acteurs aux retombées économiques pour
le territoire on a effectivement des les
oppositions mais je pense qu'à saint
brieuc ils vont trouver la solution est
en tout cas daniel grémillet
spécialiste de l'énergie chez les
républicains au sénat qui n'est pas du
tout un anti nucléaire c'est pas du tout
ce que je veux dire a quand même mis
dans la loi climat 50 gigawatts de
production installée d'éolien offshore
en france dans les prochaines décennies
c'est quand même un acte de foi
vis-à-vis de l'éolien offshore qui est
probablement une des grande énergie
aujourd'hui avec un taux de charge très
important qui va qui peut permettre
france 2 ne pas perdre les électrons est
mal choisi 5
merci effectivement on parle d'acte de
foi et effectivement j'ai l'impression
que sur cette question en tout cas du
100% renouvelable donc moi je pense que
les renouvelables sont absolument
importante est nécessaire pour
encourager la planète a sauté carbonées
et à plein d'endroits qui sont très
lourdement
dépendant des énergies fossiles charbon
et gaz pour ce qui est de leur
électricité je rappelle que l'on parle
d'électricité alors qu'en france elle à
95% des carbonnais donc c'est un jour
parler climat avec les verts j'en serais
ravi on parlera des autres 75 mais
effectivement ce que j'entends votre
part qui est le passage en force sur la
question du droit moi j'ai quand même
envie de constater qu'on a un passage en
force sur la question de la science
physique telle qu'elle a quand même
quelque chose qu'on ne dit jamais ou en
tout cas rarement et moi mon association
et il est effectivement une association
pro nucléaires de militants climat c'est
que que ce soit toutes les énergies
intermittentes qui dépendent de la météo
qu'elles soient les énergies marines
type la houle ou les éoliennes avec le
vent ou le solaire avec le soleil par
définition ce sont des énergies qui sont
intermittentes et qui n'arrive à couvrir
la production que entre 10 et 20% du
temps ce qui veut dire que le reste du
temps il faut qu'elles soient
complémentaires notamment par des
énergies fossiles c'est exactement ce
qui se passe en allemagne c'est ce qui
se passe au portugal c'est ce qui se
passe dans le sol et un pays qui tendent
vers le 100% enfin une forte pénétration
de renouvelables c'est qu'elles sont
dépendantes des énergies fossiles c'est
peut-être aussi une des raisons pour
laquelle les fameux l'autre
prend beaucoup de publicité pour ces
énergies là qui maintiennent leur
dépendance et notre dépendance vous avez
parlé de l'allemagne j'aimerais qu'on
termine en donnant un chiffre passionna
à j'avais juste un dernier très vigilant
parce que
aussi la problématique environnement
c'est à dire que moi je pense aussi
qu'il faut souligner que ces énergies
l'action des énergies très diluée encore
une fois en termes des sciences
physiques requiert énormément
d'équipement donc entraîne une grande
artificialisation des sols avec un
renouvellement des équipements qui eux
de se faire entre 15 et 20 ans il faut
régénérer les parcs sur des échelles de
temps extrêmement courte avec des
circuits de recyclage qui sont encore
pas aujourd'hui complètement mûr voilà
le débat est terminé
c'est trop vite c'était passionnant et
je
suis désolé monsieur le sénateur vous
aurez d'autres occasions de vous vous
exprimez merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat